how do you deal with like uh being
motivated being um not being anxious
being down on yourself being uh do you
deal with being ever depression at all
yeah I mean I thankfully I've been
blessed I don't I I don't want to call
it real depression you know because some
people struggle with some stuff that I
could never understand
um but I definitely get I mean human
nature to get down on yourself
um for me I get in low periods of my
life when I don't have purpose so
something I struggle with my 20s a lot
you know
what yeah acting is I did a movie with
Armin Buehler Stahl
um went called uh my brain's not working
right now um
I should know this uh
dust Factory there we go came to me uh
and when I was a kid he told me you know
to be a successful actor you need
Hobbies I didn't know what the heck he
was talking about in my head yeah he was
a painter a musician he did everything
um and I was just like as a kid I was
like that made no sense and it was until
like my 30s where I was like oh and my
20s I go crazy like when I'm working I'm
happy as a clam you know I'm so
everything's awesome and it's those down
times right that's when I get in trouble
or if I you know like I don't have
things to do or you start you know like
you get lonely or whatever so so having
purpose to keeping myself busy you know
like even just going to the gym in the
morning helps me keep my mind moving for
for a reason it's those times are like
you know like say if you just did you
just got off a series or a film you know
and you have like two months off it's
it's easy to just be like I'm just gonna
relax and for those two months I would
my it would mess with me mentally oh
yeah rather than you know you'd think
like oh spiral yeah I'm I'm that's good
for my health I'm taking a break no I
need to have things to do to to make it
so like you know because the average
person they have a nine to five and you
know they just they just keep going
through it for me I'm meant for that not
nine to five but like staying busy
because when I have down time that's
when I get into trouble that's when I do
stupid things that's when I I just do
dumb things when I have too much free
time and I get down on myself the most
dangerous word in the dictionary
sedentary
foreign
that's what when I'm just not doing
anything just sitting there
I think everything's fine I could watch
a movie and then the movie's over and
then I'm thinking
what am I doing I put on another movie
that I'm thinking and I'll go upstairs
thinking yeah it's it's like you know
some people need to be busy I think
everyone needs to have a little actions
yeah and you know I said it millions of
times but you don't have to
you know be a a movie star You Don't
Have To Be A Millionaire to be happy or
have Passions
everyone loves something everyone loves
doing something
besides watching TV and like you know
going out for a hike or you know going
to play softball with friends or
learning guitar or whatever it is
Hobbies Hobbies like he said it's so
it's so true like I have that's the
thing I have a lot of hobbies you know a
lot and that's thank God for those thank
God for still playing some sports and
still playing guitar and music and all
this stuff
because those lulls can get you yeah
especially when you're young and you're
always like you're always working and
going to this and hey we're going to
this party and hey we're going here hey
going to Toronto you're gonna shoot this
and you're gonna and then all of a
sudden everything stops and you're like
who am I what the f what am I doing here